good morning believe nation today's
message is create memorable experiences
over to you Jurgen Klopp how would you
describe your football in philosophy
lively I think it's it's not the
smartest way I know so and it's it and
now it's an all success yeah and they
add that's how it is a success rate it's
cool too but first of all having
memorable games in a row that's my first
target that the people really want to
see the next game you leave the stage
when you want to see the next game you
can't wait for the next game that's what
football should be and if you can do
this very often and you will be
successful 100% so I think this is a
message that entrepreneurs can learn
from too I think that we want to create
memorable experiences in our business I
think you should be excited about the
work that you're gonna do every day and
yes you're gonna have bad times and not
everything is gonna be amazing and rosy
but at the end of the day you should be
excited what the work you're doing you
should feel like the work that you are
creating is valuable is important is
memorable that what you did today is
going to matter I think that's why a lot
of people become entrepreneurs it's
because you want your work no matter
because you don't want to work for the
man you don't want to work at some job
where you're not important when you're
not having an impact and so I think if
you are not in that situation where you
feel like the work that you are doing is
important is meaningful is valuable to
yourself and to the community to the
people around you to your customers then
that's when you need to start to change
something I think a lot of entrepreneurs
who go into business just trying to make
a lot of money those are the ones who
fail because they're not trying to have
an impact because they're not trying to
create something memorable because
they're not trying to create something
they can show their grandkids and say
look at what I did look at what I
created look at the impact that I had
that needs to be part of your motivation
that every day you wake up and you're
doing something that's going to matter
to somebody it fuels you and I think if
you look at yourself in the mirror for
too many days in a row and you find that
the work you're doing
is meaningless is not really having a
big impact then you owe it to yourself
to make a change you owe it to yourself
your to your family or to community or
to the world to make a change to do
something different and you apply the
same strategy same mindset mentality to
everything that you do you apply it to
your relationships you apply it to your
friendships you apply it to your life
you want the time that you spend on
anything to matter and one of the things
that I routinely do is a self audit at
least every couple of months I'll do a
self audit to look at where am i
spending my time and does it matter and
the more that I'm spending time on
things that don't matter that don't
matter to me that don't matter to other
people it's not having an impact
somewhere then I drop those things and
move on to something else
and you owe it to yourself to take the
greatness that's within you and create
something amazing with it and stop
spending time on things that do not
matter if you spent more time on
creating amazing and memorable
experiences you're gonna feel more
fulfilled you're gonna feel more
successful you're gonna have a lot more
money and you're gonna make a much
greater impact on the world and the
people around so the question they today
is I'm curious what do you love most
about your business and what you do
every day that creates memories leaving
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Tom Torrez Tom thank
you so much you're picking up a copy of
my book you're one word it really really
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
hey belief nation has a special bonus
for those of you interested in learning
more about creating memorable
experiences we've lined up a few more
clips that I think will help well I said
that the most important thing is the
product and that really is true because
you can have all the advertising in the
world you can have all the hype and when
people go to the store if they try on
your pants and they don't look good and
they don't fit or they don't like the
fabric they're not gonna buy them but to
get them into the store to get them
there you need the other part of the
equation you need to excite them and you
need you know pants or pants I mean
fashion you know one pair of black pants
and the other pair of black pants you
know so you have to make fashion
aspirational you have to make people
believe that if they just have those
pants their whole life is going to come
together they're gonna get that guy they
want they're gonna get that new job
they're gonna get you know it's because
and that's just as much as a part of the
experience and and it actually again
that sounds like a terrible very
calculated thing but it's not because by
creating that image you have endowed
another quality onto that pair of pants
or pair of shoes that really you know
makes it something else and make sure
experience of wearing that thing
something else and enhances your life if
it all gives you confidence to bring out
the worst in that's the word they give
to the comp is to bring out the best in
you that's in its contributed to your
absolutely well-being absolutely every
Hotel I've ever built has been the
highest-grossing casino in any city
we've ever been period the largest
amount of money ever won by a licensed
casino in the state of Nevada when I
built it was Mirage that record was
broken when we built Bellagio and then
the current record is held by Wynn Las
Vegas seven hundred and seventy million
dollars in casino revenue last year that
was more than anybody else in the
history of the state 170 odd million was
slot machines six hundred million was
tables of the six hundred million in
tables fifty-two percent of it was from
Asia 24 percent was from Latin America
twenty four percent was in the United
States
interesting huh 450 million out of 600
million was from outside the United
States why are people from San Paolo
Brazil Rio de Janeiro Buenos Aires
Bogota Colombia Monterrey Mexico Mexico
City these are where we have offices
Hong Kong Taiwan Seoul Korea Tokyo and
all over mainland China why do they get
on airplanes fly over other casinos to
come to Las Vegas because of the
atmosphere because of wonderful service
because of a great hotel staff because
it's fun to be there with the a gamble
or you don't and and although we broke
the record at 770 million for a casino
revenue for any licensee in the history
of Nevada the non casino revenue was 860
million over half yup and it's the 860
that made it possible for the 770 I'm
going through all this with you all to
explain to you our attitude why we do
what we do and what really matters in
our business and it's to words and
everything else is baloney forget all
about the movies and the Hollywood and
the eye in the sky and the security one
thing one thing matters to the state of
Massachusetts if it cares about revenue
and jobs guest experience if people have
a good time if they're well served if
they're in an atmosphere that's exciting
and stimulating they come back again
they're willing to pay more money next
year a little more than they paid this
year so that we can cover the increasing
cost of doing business
unions need increases people want to get
paid more money cost of living goes up
you get a franchise because people have
a good experience and when you give
people a good experience they come from
outside the region into the region and
if you want to get people from over
there to come over here you better build
something here
that's better than their we collect this
year about eight billion dollars of
customers money so thank you all of you
for giving us your money
and what we do is we say that money is
entrust to create joy we have to turn
that into the most joy possible and so
we look and we say for every show if a
show cost a hundred million dollars how
much joy
how much viewing did it create amongst
all of you if it cost 50 million or 200
million of course you want different
amounts of joy so we look at it as how
much joy can we create of your money and
if we turn it into joy effectively then
you're happy and you tell your friends
and we grow and then we have more money
next year to turn into more joy so we
think of ourselves like alchemists we
take in money and out comes joy add some
value there's a true societal and
business value proposition there's a
contribution I find and I don't do this
for reasons other than the fact that you
can't long-term build a viable business
without making a real contribution most
people look at they can start a business
do an IPO make some money almost always
that leads to businesses that are round
trips what I call good they go up and go
down to build a durable business you
really have to focus on the value
proposition